en lice face participation massive et
dans le calme aux élections en roumanie
le point en direct à bucarest dans un
instant
en israël la journée la plus meurtrière
dans les territoires occupés depuis le
début de l'intifada
la contre attaque de valéry giscard
d'estaing ni accord ni contact avec le
front national
premier bilan au festival de cannes
notre invité la roxane de cyrano la
comédienne anne brochet bonsoir 15 morts
et 400 blessés aujourd'hui il escalade
de la violence dans les territoires
occupés par israël point de départ un
attentat sanglant commis ce matin par un
israélien contre un groupe de
travailleurs palestiniens au sud de
tel-aviv huit morts dans cet attentat et
nouvelle flambée de violence cet
après-midi commentaire hélène risacher
la journée la plus meurtrière depuis le
début de l'intifada en 87
depuis ce matin en cisjordanie et
surtout à gaza toute la population
fallait souvent dans les rues les
patrouilles de soldats disent alliance
on s'attaquait aux pierres des cocktails
molotov arif hausse à balles réelles
résultat au moins 15 palestiniens tués
ce soir et plus de 500 blessés étaient
encore une tuerie qui a mis le feu aux
poudres ce matin à rishon le tzion dans
la banlieue de tel aviv un israéliens
déguisés en soldats a vidé le chargeur
de son fusil d'assaut m16 à bout portant
sur un groupe de palestiniens huit ans
une dizaine de blessés dont plusieurs
grièvement touché à la tête ou au vent
les palestiniens des territoires se
rendaient à leur travail en israël
lorsque le jeune israélien les a
attaqués
le tueur a été arrêté selon la police il
s'agirait d'un repris de justice
l'attentât a été vigoureusement condamné
par toute la classe politique
israélienne le chef du gouvernement il
cherche à meerab énoncé cet acte de
folie et il a demandé aux palestiniens
de ne pas répondre à la violence par la
violence
mais du côté palestinien on accuse les
dirigeants d'israël extrémistes et et
oiseaux peuvent être responsables de
cette tuerie
ce soir le chef de l'olp et yasser
arafat appelle à la poursuite de
l'intifada jusqu'à la victoire
ils demandent des sanctions
internationales contre israël ainsi que
l'aide politique et humanitaire de la
france dès l'annoncé de l'attentât de
rishon des centaines de palestiniens des
territoires travaille en famille
elles sont repartis chez eux arborant
des drapeaux noirs en signe de deuil et
syndicats palestiniens ont appelé à
trois jours de grève générale
les affrontements entre palestiniens et
soldats israéliens a continué ce soir un
enchaînement de violences qui
fragilisent encore toute tentative mais
un processus de paix en roumanie les
partis d'opposition ont dénoncé
aujourd'hui encore des irrégularités
dans le déroulement des premières
élections libres depuis 1946 le taux de
participation s'annonce ce soir très
élevé les roumains ont voté dans le
calme sous le regard d'observateurs
étrangers parmi lesquels une française
suivi aujourd'hui par jérôme cathala
premières constatations dans ce bureau
de vote
musique occidentale pour adoucir les
moeurs ou anesthésier les consciences
plus mot d'ordre sans équivoque égale
rock massif pour le front de salut
national
une très simple équation rapidement
formulée par l'un des observateurs
français sonia mine ils ont montré des
bulletins qui étaient annulés mais où
croyez y avait plusieurs tampon à
d'annulation il croyait que c'était les
partis qui étaient annulés et de toute
façon il est étonnant que des gens qui
n'ont pas encore voté des bulletins de
vote
le bulletin de vote sont juste derrière
et j'ai vu des personnes se sont à
nouveau tendus autant bourrages d'urnes
j'appelle du bourrage d'urnes
village après village les observateurs
français interroge les scrutateurs et la
population partout les mêmes difficultés
il faut dire que le vote n'est pas
exactement une habitude en roumanie
et puis la procédure n'est pas des plus
simples il faut en poney la liste
choisie sur chacun des trois bulletins
de vote résidentiel l'effet sénatoriales
avant de glisser le tout dans une
enveloppe opération compliquée pour une
grande partie de la population surtout
dans les campagnes
enfin les responsables des bureaux de
vote n'ont semble-t-il pas toujours été
choisi avec un grand souci d'équilibré
politique que nous avons vu des
personnes avec des brassards qui contre
les enveloppes qui les rouvre et qui est
d'après les dires de la plupart des
personnes ont été désignées uniquement
par le monde et qui vérifie le contenu
les emplois bref des dizaines de petites
irrégularités qui ne permettent pas de
parler de manipulation mais pour sonia
ming qui a suivi les élections en
pologne et en hongrie
ce triple scrutin ressemble peu à ce
qu'elle avait observée là bas toutes les
conditions de démocratie et partout dans
chaque bureau de vote étaient garantis y
avait des représentants de tous les
partis
je crois que c'est là la presse et puis
la campagne électorale tout le monde
la campagne s'est déroulée de façon
régulière avec un peu près le même accès
à la télévision ce qui n'a pas été le
cas ici
enfin l'extrême lenteur des opérations
pourrait empêcher un grand nombre
d'électeurs de voter
résultat on parle déjà ici de laisser
les bureaux ouverts toute la nuit il le
faut mémona hintermann en direct à
bucarest
quelle est l'ambiance ce soir dans la
ville de bucarest la mobilisation reste
très importante autour de ces élections
mobilisés ce très importante et vous
voyez ils sont autour de moi et au vin
de bonne humeur îlots mais si zoé peu de
méfiance cependant parce qu'on a parlé
encore de possibilités de fraudes mais
les gens attendent les opérations
électorales devraient se poursuivre
jusqu'à très tard dans la nuit
puisque manifestement beaucoup journaux
pas encore voté d'après la ligue
roumaine des droits de l'homme à 6
heures seulement 50% des inscrits
avaient voté non pas parce qu'il manque
d' enthousiasme ils attendaient
patiemment et pendant très longtemps
toute la journée et simplement parce que
les opérations du vote semble être assez
compliqué assez difficile pour des gens
qui n'ont pas l'habitude
alors bien sûr dans ce contexte mais
mona il faut prendre tous les sondages
et toutes les appréciations avec
beaucoup de prudence parce que on l'a vu
dans le reportage de jérôme cathala
ces élections vont être soumises sinon
la réprobation du mont à quelques
suspicions vous avez des premières
indications quand même sur ce que
pourraient être les résultats écoutez au
match de toute haleine dernières
indications il faut la prendre comme
elles et elles viennent du parti
national paysans ratio le candidat le
seul pays 0 9%
quand pernoud le candidat libéral 37% et
ue les coûts 54%
on nous a dit également que beaucoup de
gens voulaient voter you lescout parce
qu'il était si populaire ici ce qui ne
signifie pas qu'ils allaient voter
massivement pour les candidats du
programme national comme quoi tordre on
a bien dit que l'allemagne de l'est les
sondages se sont trompés et il se peut
que de la journée certains ont pu
jugé autrement alors même on a derrière
ces trois grandes formations politiques
que vous venez de citer il ya aussi des
écologistes en roumanie
quelle est leur espoir ce soir de
figurer au moins au parlement ces jours
ci ont crédité les écologistes est de
environ 7% des intentions de vote mais
en discutant avec les gens on s'est
rendu compte que l'écologie la
protection de l'environnement était une
question d'importance ils disent que
c'est une priorité
ça ne veut pas dire ils reconnaissent
qu'ils vont voter pour les écologistes
parce que vous voulez le vote est trop
politisés pour cela ils se disent que
dans les 18 mois qui viennent il faudra
se battre pour que la conception
générale de la société soit imposé donc
l'écologie ce sera pour plus tard et
vous avez un vrai désastre écologique de
ce pays
tout à fait nous allons voir avec le
reportage merci mémona hintermann ce
reportage de philippe pisteurs qui
démontre qu ici le gouvernement roumain
est intervenue dans les cas les plus
flagrants
pour lutter contre la pollution il en
reste encore bien d'autres aujourd'hui
l'exemple d'une pollution ordinaire en
roumanie vu par philippe pfister dont tu
es marque doux comme harnik une petite
vie d'encaisser dans la vallée de
prahova à une centaine de kilomètres de
bucarest
de loin elle ressemble à bien d'autres
villes mais a comme harnik à les toits
de tuiles rouges sont blancs comme et
blanchette poudre qui partout dit lui
les couleurs insidieusement empoisonnent
les habitants en grande partie
responsable cette cimenterie construite
il ya plus d'un siècle conditions de
travail déplorables et n'ont quasiment
pas changé depuis
l'usiné emploie quelques 700 personnes
pas d'équipements spéciaux même pas de
masque pourtant pour le contremaître ici
il n'y a aucun problème chez nous il
n'ya pas de silicose pas de maladies
respiratoires pas de maladies
professionnelles
il n'a jamais eu en la présence
constante du contremaître aucun les
ouvriers interrogés avouent être malade
ou être au courant de cas de maladies
non non il n'y a pas de mal à l'itie
prades
bal à damas ils ne disent pas toute la
vérité et le chef d'equipe ne veux pas
avoir un problème avec la direction
la poudre ciment provoque des bronchites
une bronchite asthmatiques les allergies
de la peau et de nombreuses maladies
respiratoires 7 jours sur 7 la
cimenterie crash et déverse sa poudre
blanche sur la ville
et encore la situation s'est améliorée
avec l'installation de filtres il ya
seulement dix ans mais redoutable
privilège comme harnik possède également
deux autres usines
nous avons des problèmes respiratoires
aussi à cause de la fabrique de produits
réfractaires
regardez la poudre sur les meubles
chaque matin ma femme fait pourtant
ménages le voisin monsieur turque où est
tombé malade et les membres de silicose
du poumon silicose emphysème pulmonaire
asthme bronchites chroniques allergies
toute affection anormalement sûr
représenté a comme harnik mais difficile
d'obtenir des statistiques exactes sous
changer ce qu elle était plutôt mal vu
ou truqué les malades n'étaient
pratiquement pas répertorié les cas
graves envoyés à bucarest il
n'apparaissait pas sur les chiffres
locaux comme harnik n'est pas un cas
extrême une ville parmi bien d'autres
comme celle ci 50 kilomètres plus loin
plus riches qui est son combinant
industrielle aujourd'hui des mouvements
écologistes naisse un peu partout la
roumanie découvre les désastres occulté
par la dictature politique en france la
contre attaque de valéry giscard
d'estaing il a répondu à ceux qui
l'accusaient de rester silencieux face
au front national reportage
eric peron après être resté étrangement
discret pendant dix jours valéry giscard
d'estaing a tenu ce matin à mettre un
terme aux doutes qui commençait à
s'installer
il a condamné clairement les événements
odieux de carpentras la france at il
ajouté ne se reconnaît pas dans ses
horreurs
valéry giscard d'estaing a tenu
également à répondre à ses amis
chiraquien qui avait observé une
certaine complaisance de sa part à
l'égard du front national
je ne pratique pas l'insultent vis-à-vis
de jean-marie le pen
pourquoi parce que je n'insulte personne
mais la courtoisie n'est pas la
compromission
je n'ai aucun contact direct ou indirect
avec jean marie le pen comme certains
esprits tordus cherche à le faire croire
et je me prêterait à aucun accord
politique
nos valeurs sont incompatibles et chacun
a pu vérifier que je ne transige pas sur
mes valeurs je les lis car destin accusé
également sur le nommer françois
mitterrand d'avoir favoriser l'extrême
droite pour mieux diviser la droite
notre rôle au contraire est de détacher
de l'extrême droite et de ramener vers
l'opposition libérale toutes celles et
tous ceux qui votaient pour elle et qui
s'en sont éloignés pour émettre un vote
de protestation pour cela valéry giscard
d'estaing entend s'inspirer de la
stratégie utilisée par françois
mitterrand à l'égard du parti communiste
dans les années 70 le président de l'idf
ne signera pas de programme commun avec
le front national
mais il veut obtenir le même résultat
être réélu à la présidence de la
république ce qui attise déjà la
rivalité avec jacques chirac d'avoir les
clubs perspectives et réalités encore le
maire de sartrouville a apporté une
nouvelle pièce au dossier des
municipalités confrontés aux problèmes
d'immigration clandestine laurent vide
elle refuse désormais de signer tout
certificat d'hébergement pour les
étrangers et sa décision pourrait ne pas
rester isolé à sartrouville dans les
yvelines reportage de clément
weill-raynal sartrouville interdit aux
étrangers
pas du tout répond son maire laurent
vettel qui a néanmoins décidé de se
placer dans l'illégalité en refusant de
signer désormais les certificats
d'hébergement et attestation d'accueil
des documents nécessaires aux étrangers
arrivant en france pour une visite dite
privée et que le maire de la commune
d'accueil doit signer aux termes de la
loi mais sans aucune possibilité de
vérification les étrangers en question
qui viennent pour une visite privée de
moins de 3 mois ne peuvent pas être
hébergés normalement sur sarthe
il est au bout de trois mois ne quitte
pas ma commune devienne à ce moment là
des irréguliers des clandestins si on
veut et sont finalement régularisés il y
en a 16 cents qui seront arrivés sur
sartrouville en 1990 si j'extrapole à
partir des chiffres dont dispose
aujourd'hui sur 50 mille habitants 16
cents par an c'est considérable laurent
wenzel se défend de tout racisme
xénophobie
maire depuis un an après 30 ans de
présence comme unis il lance un appel
aux autres maires de france pour qu'ils
refusent à leur tour de signer les
certificats d'accueil véritable caution
selon ses termes à l'immigration
clandestine
bien sûr c'est illégal reconnaît le
maire de sartrouville mais c'est au
gouvernement de prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent
selon laurent wenzel beaucoup de mères
en france de toutes tendances politiques
pratiquent déjà de manière plus ou moins
déguisés
le refus de signature environnement en
moselle une importante pollution de la
rivière la cei a tué tous les poissons
depuis hier sur son parcours en moselle
soit une trentaine sur une trentaine de
kilomètres les l'origine est encore
difficile à déterminer la langue
progression de la pollution fait penser
plutôt un produit lourd du lindane
peut-être cette molécule que l'on
retrouve dans les fongicides
actuellement utilisés par les
agriculteurs pour traiter les blés il
faudra attendre au moins trois ans pour
pouvoir songer à recommencer une
activité de pêche dans la cei en sport
fignon décroché dans le giro la revanche
de l'équipe de france de volley-ball
face au brésil le sport en bref avec le
commentaire de reining audit chez nous
l'heure de la revanche cet après midi à
nantes pour l'équipe de france de
volley-ball tilly maçons et les autres
bat avec la manière une bonne équipe
brésilienne en quatre sets
désormais l'équipe de france peut croire
aux demi finales de cette ligue mondiale
de volley ball
un rendez vous prévu à osaka les 14 et
15 juillet prochains pour une fois la
tristesse de che snopkov s'explique
aujourd'hui l'autrichien thomas muster a
cogné encore plus fort que d'habitude en
finale des internationaux d'italie
tchesnokov impuissant et fatigué perd en
trois sets 6 1 6 3 6 1
le bonheur de monica seles au tournoi de
berlin ouest à 16 ans la jeune
yougoslave pas dans son jardin steffi
graf en deux sets 6 4 6 3 monica seles
met fin à une série de 66 victoires
d'affilée pour steffi graf
eduardo chozas roi du vésuve dans la 3e
étape du giro
gianni bugno conserve son maillot rose
après une fin de course époustouflante
qui le fait terminé second à quelques
longueurs de choses à ce film y ont
perdu 0,5 sur le vainqueur dans
l'ascension et se retrouve quatrième une
08 de bougneau au classement général
le cinéma avec les images en principe
toute chose de l'arrivée de marcello
mastroianni sur les marches du palais du
festival de cannes vous le voyez marché
le match ciani venu présenter cet amour
tutti bene le dernier film du metteur en
scène bien sûr tueuse effet tornato ré
max royal y inviter en principe dans
soir 3 avec henry chapier henry chapier
que nous retrouvons en direct à cannes
aux côtés de la comédienne anne brochet
la ravissante roxane de cyrano qui a
vécu son premier festival je crois en
brochets oui oui tout à fait non c'était
pas du tout premier festival c'était le
troisième est fait dans ces conditions
alors dans ces conditions là vous êtes
se soit ému séduit tous déjà blasé
malheureusement pas du tout blasé je
suis complètement ému et pour l'instant
je n'arrive pas du tout à me rends
compte de ce qui s'est passé
mon avis ça va être dans quelques jours
quand tout va ressortir bel eric joray
vous dire que le succès de cyrano est
telle que la pour arriver au plateau
pour arriver à vous parler et bien à
traverser franchement une foule de fans
une foule de spectateurs ravis qu'ils
ont jetés littéralement sur anne brochet
et qui réclame évidemment que cyrano est
un prix jouer vous le dire alors anne
justement roxane qui a fait tourner la
tête de tous ces hommes dans tout le
monde connaît l'histoire d'alors est ce
que vous vous trouvez qu'aujourd'hui si
le film était adaptée si c'est un cyrano
en costumes haut d'un an comme on est là
tous les deux
est ce que c'est possible qu'une roxane
ne sentent pas qu'elle était mais à ce
point c'est une hypothèse d'école
oui aussi je crois que ça change rien du
tout c'est pas le l'ailé sociale enfin
pour moi du du thème de du film et de la
pièce bien sûr c'est pas c'est un thème
universel quoi toutes avérées la femme
et le centre vous êtes le centre nous là
et comme actrice c'est vous qui
déclenche c'est tout votre personnage
anne brochet avez vous le sentiment que
la sortie le fait que le film cyrano de
bergerac soit sorti avant sa projection
à cannes c'est un atout ou un handicap
pour obtenir la palme d'or une pose des
questions mais génère mais ça ne vous
répondrai sur votre visage et votre
sentiment je pense que c'est ça va ça
n'a aucun rapport que c'est un marché
international créé un festival
international et c'est une rencontre de
films de tous les pays et qu'il soit
sorti dans son pays d'origine et
n'importe pas mais je crois qu'elle a
tout à fait raison mais est ce que ça
sera comme ça vous voyez l'a fait devant
suspense devant je ne sais pas du tout
mais vous sentez je me dis que peut-être
si le film était sortie n'avait été
projetée qui hier soir et donc n'était
pas sorti le 28 mars serait peut-être pu
faire un tapage encore plus puissant
vous soyez sûr d'avoir la palme dès ce
soir peut-être regarder mains des
personnes en plus des champs regardez en
tout cas maintenant comment faire
l'événement à cannes quand il ne s'y
passe rien vous prenez deux journalistes
de talent en l'occurrence jean françois
grégoire et christophe airaud vous
recruter de jeunes comédiens inconnus
mais qui rêve de faire carrière et vous
fait croire à l'arrivée d'une superstar
sur la croisette
effet garanti jugez vous même oublié
pour une heure les galères de
rendez-vous les castings et les
embrouilles en tout genre nous avons
offert à trois jeunes comédiens à un
après-midi de stars un film bidon trois
acteurs totalement inconnu mais une
voiture officielle défaut ce groupe i
une équipe de télé qui a tenté vous
le mot les stars et qui se fait un
plaisir de le faire savoir autour d'elle
vous suffit à temps d'en parler même
temps en infos voilà pourquoi les dix
minutes seulement pour exciter la
curiosité et provoqué un rassemblement
et à l'arrivée des illustres inconnus la
foule réagi si vite qu'elle nous empêche
d'approcher la voiture est à cet instant
précis fosseux star et vrais
journalistes sont complètement dépassés
par les événements
nous atteignons péniblement l'escalier
pour notre hymne cardio exclusive
mais impossible de travailler même s'ils
ont du mal à mettre des noms sur les
visages des photographes assure les
cours
repli stratégique sur la terrasse du
carlton et c'est le moment ou jamais
pour une photo souvenir ou un autographe
mais moi aussi j'ai eu du mal à le
reconnaître mais enfin je je veux qu'ils
étaient bien quoi comme l'a dit lui même
mieux qu'elle était celui du son à
droite
c'est la raison pour laquelle on s'est
attardé on a décidé qu'il fallait jouer
on l'a joué c'est vrai que c'était drôle
c'est vrai que c'était drôle de voir la
crédibilité et la naïveté des gens c'est
drôle voilà deux comédiens peut-être
promis à un grand avenir je vous invite
maintenant aux courses ni à longchamp ni
à saint cloud mais à moscou la capitale
soviétique possède un hippodrome depuis
1837 et si le système communiste en la
modifier le fonctionnement
il n'a pas empêché la survie de cet
hippodrome et on parlerait maintenant
d'une coopération avec le pmu français
reportage à moscou de jean-pierre
quinson et de crise toscane il y ait
trois fois par semaine 10 à 15000
spectateurs envahissent l'hippodrome de
moscou l'entrée ne coûte que 40 kopeck
l'équivalent de 40 centimes et pour ce
prix le premier spectacle est dans les
tribunes
côté
hahaha
pas tout à fait
ici peu de représentants de la
nomenclature à mais un étonnant
contraste entre une architecture
rappelant les faces des tares et un
public très populaire jeu vient toutes
les semaines c'est mon plaisir
moi ce que j'aime avant tout c'est les
chevaux je viens surtout ici pour moi il
y a neuf courses par réunion disputée
par des chevaux appartenant à des fermes
d'état
un peu comme si en france le haras de
cluny affronter celui de saint lô tout
de pompadour des chevaux en provenance
d'élevage locaux mais aussi de finlande
et même des usa
les compétiteurs dans l'ensemble de
qualité moyenne pour les connaisseurs
pirouette que l'on voit ici après son
succès sur 700 m dans le prix de la
victoire l'a emporté sur le pied de u19
au kilomètre une victoire qui rapporte 4
mille roubles environ 4000 francs à sa
ferme propriétaire mais en pays
socialistes le jeu conserve ses droits
il existe des paris gagnants jumelées et
hier c'est en moyenne 450 mille roubles
sont misés à chaque réunion
en fait le véritable développement du
jeu en urss et du pmu français qu'il
pourrait venir
on a convenu de l'installer les quelques
points de vente de tickets du système
prévu dans quelques quartiers de moscou
pour en quelque sorte de test pour voir
si ça marche ou pas la coopération
sportive essaye aussi de se développer
la participation d'un cheval soviétique
au prochain prix d'amérique à vincennes
est sérieusement envisagée et pour
gagner au tiercé en france aujourd'hui
il fallait jouer le cap le 8 et le 17
tout de suite la météo complète de
florence klein je vous retrouve à 22h10
pour soir 3 avons des dictionnaires